[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
كيدي اهلا اهلا انا النحله جئت اليكم احمل
عسلا حلوا وشهيه ومفيدا للصحه هو دوما
اغلى اهلا اهلا انا النحله جئت اليكم احمل
عسلا حلوا وشيا ومفيدا للصحه هو دوما اغلى
نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله
نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله
نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله
نحله نحله نحوله غابات اسكن وحقول انا بين
الازهار اصول غابات اسكن وحقول انا بين
الازهار اصول بنشاط وبحي اعمل بتفان واقول
انا النحله زن زن زن اهلا اهلا انا النحله
جئت اليكم احمل عسلا حلوا وشهيه ومفيدا
للصحه هو دوما اغلى اهلا اهلا انا النحله
جئت اليكم احمل عسلا حلوا وشيا ومفيدا
للصحه هو دوما اغلى في عسل للناس شفاه من
امراض او ادواء في عسل للناس شفاء من
امراض او ادواء ورح قن اجمعه بجد اجعله لي
اشهى غذاء انا النحله نحله نحله نحوله
نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله
نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله
نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله
انا دوما اسعى في حركه رمز للخير ولبر انا
دوما اسعى في في حركه رمز للخير ولبر
والاجمل بين الحشرات حيوني نح ل الملكه
انا الملكه اهلا اهلا انا النحله جئت
اليكم احمل عسلا حلوا وشهيه ومفيدا للصحه
هو دوما اغلى اهلا اهلا انا النحله جئت
هو دوما اغلى نحلى نحلى نحوله نحله نحله
نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله
نحله نحله نحوله نحله نحله نحوله نحله
نحله نحوله نحله نحله
نحوله